hello emily hello david so we're here
today to talk about apoptosis uh i was
going to ask you some questions about it
you were going to explain
what it even is
to me
absolutely okay talk apoptosis so so
this word apoptosis i did a little bit
of
etymology research i broke the word
apart because it comes from greek
particles that i
identified so we have here's here's the
limit of what i know right now
so it comes from these two pieces the
oppo meaning away
and ptosis which means like a falling
so it's really this kind of it means
like to the falling away and my
understanding is that
this programmed cell death because
that's what it is that's what you've
written is kind of
analogous to leaves falling away from a
tree that it's something that's supposed
to happen
and the cells just die in this
prescribed way when they're supposed to
this isn't random this is this is
something that the cell
embarks on for a particular purpose
yeah i think that's a really a good way
of putting it and i think that is why it
was named apoptosis by some of the first
folks who studied it on is that they
really wanted to underscore that this is
a form of cell death that is a normal
healthy part of an organism's
development its maintenance of its body
even its prevention of things like viral
infection or cancer um so it's very much
a normal and healthy thing
that your body is actually doing right
now
right now right now oh man
so okay so what
what are the ways in which a cell can
die
what are i mean because
we have this diagram here here's a
here's a normal healthy cell and then
here we've got this what looks like the
aftermath of some kind of explosion what
is what is this
so that's sort of showing two very broad
categories of ways that a cell can die
and
the simplest way to label them would be
messy and tidy
but more more formally the bursting
looking cell is undergoing necrosis
which is a form of cell death where the
cell basically swells up and explodes
and it releases its contents which is
not very good because those can damage
other cells in the area they can attract
cells of the immune system that will
cause inflammation and then on the flip
side
you have the the tidy approach apoptosis
um and here you actually see the cell
shrinking down and kind of uh breaking
up its dna breaking up that's nuclear
these little orange things in here are
the chromosomes being cut apart so those
are like really little fragments of
chromosome they'd actually be much
littler even than what i've drawn there
but but what the cell's going to do is
it's just kind of going to come apart
into little fragments encircling
different cell components on so you can
sort of see those starting to bud off
and then cells from the immune system
whose job is basically to gobble up
debris they're going to come and eat
those little fragments it's going to be
like nothing ever happened so this is
kind of the difference between
disposing of your garbage in trash bags
and disposing of your garbage by just
dumping it out the window of your
apartment
yes i think that's true but maybe even
taking it a step further if you dispose
of your garbage in trash bags or by
apoptosis you can actually reuse what
was in the garbage interesting so so
other cells can use those components on
for their own purposes and they won't
suffer any damage from having nasty
stuff floating around outside
so what
what are the circumstances under which
apoptosis happens like how how how
common is this and
how common is necrosis
um
so necrosis is usually something that
that your body does not want to happen
that's going to happen when a cell is
perhaps exposed to a chemical toxin when
a cell is actually mechanically damaged
on
so those are circumstances where a cell
has basically received an insult that
has caused it to die in a not very
controlled way okay on
and apoptosis is kind of something that
would be going on basically from the
time
a human being or another vertebrate is a
tiny embryo
throughout its life on so when you're
developing
when you're developing your hands your
hand actually kind of starts out as this
chunk of tissue that's kind of like a
paddle okay and it's actually apoptosis
that is going to whittle your fingers
out of that block
so
so i've got i've got this hand right
i've got this kind of like webby hand
and you're telling me that as the hand
develops
the tissue gets reabsorbed into the
other cells that we're gonna make up the
rest of my hand
yeah so the cells they'll first die by
apoptosis and then basically the blebs
will get scavenged up i'm sorry the what
i guess i never named them but these are
called
the little protrusions that's a very
technical term
i love that
you'll see it in scientifically that's a
science word it's totally scientific i
love that all right
okay you can you can also see them in
the uh the the picture right what is
this what is this image here on so those
are that's basically just the same thing
that the line diagram is showing healthy
cells which is the left panel and then
blebby cells undergoing apoptosis which
is the right panel so they're having all
of their cell components repackaged into
garbage bags to be or if we want
recycling bags then to be sent off to
other cells where their components can
be reused as stuff exactly okay
now what's this what's this um
this tadpole
beast here what is this about so that's
kind of the same thing that we were
talking about with the hand on but
another place where you see apoptosis
happening in development is when you
have a tadpole metamorphosing into a
frog on
so tadpoles this is actually kind of
part of the way they're already
the tadpoles have a very long tail and
frogs generally don't have much of a
tail to speak of and the way that the
frog loses its tail is through apoptosis
um and again
it's it's said to resorb the tail so
that it can make use of the cellular
components cool
so tail just sort of shoots up and
becomes hindquarters
yeah i don't actually know exactly
you know if it starts from the end and
eats its way inward but on
somehow it gets removed developmentally
man that's really cool
so it's not it's not it's not really
like leaves falling off a tree it's not
like this is a
three-toed skink or something if you
grabbed a metamorphosing tadpole by the
tail it would just break off
it's really more that it gradually gets
subsumed into the the tissue of the
growing frog
i mean at the cellular level i guess the
cells do they pull away from their
neighbors so in that sense it's a
falling off but it's not necessarily a
falling off that you see as at the level
of a whole organ it would be more of
falling off of an individual cell so so
far we've given examples of
of apoptosis that are happening within
developing
uh creatures but you're saying that
within like right now apoptosis is
happening in my body
and in fact so does that mean is that
just to keep the number of cells in my
body constant
that's a big part of the role that
apoptosis plays on like your your blood
system in particular is continually
producing new cells and
if you produce cells but you never got
rid of cells you would eventually end up
with too many cells and
too many cells in general is not a great
thing to have in the human body that's
the kind of thing that you might get in
cancer if you're having cells
accumulating too much on
so part of it is just keeping a healthy
balance but since we also just brought
up cancer that's actually another
wonderful favor that all of our cells
are doing for us
is if they suffer dna damage which could
predispose them to become cancerous
first they'll try to fix it but if they
can't fix it they will actually under
normal circumstances undergo apoptosis
so there's no chance of them passing
that damage on and becoming cancerous
and that's actually a really important
protective role that that apoptosis
plays in an adult human or in a human at
any stage of their life
so it's kind of like
um like a big red button
that you know it's like a self-destruct
button if if a cell
comes to
appreciate that it is developing
cancerous symptoms then it just hits the
button and begins this cascade of
enzymes that cause it to undergo
apoptosis
yeah i mean i think that's the the
general way to think of it for sure on
so there are actually kind of different
ways that cells that are progressing
towards cancer might be stopped and some
of those involve
internal mechanisms so the cell doing
its own surveillance and observing wow g
my dna does not look good and i can't
fix it okay but also you could have a
cell that
might be observable from the outside by
another cell as a potential cancer cell
so like an immune cell could come by and
like stick a protein on the outside that
also triggers the same thing
yeah yeah i don't um i don't know
exactly what the mechanism of
communication there is but it would be
an interaction between the two cells
where one of them would tell the other
you know okay i see there's something
wrong with you you know time to time to
wrap this up cool so apoptosis can
happen in a couple of ways but in
pretty much all cases it is a normal
healthy part of the cell life cycle do
all cells die this way
um i mean there are cells that will will
undergo necrosis on so certainly
in that sense not every cell in your
body is going to die by apoptosis on
i would imagine that there are also
other ways of recycling used cells that
are not
exactly considered apoptosis on
like skin cells
some of them will undergo kind of a
similar process but it's not technically
apoptosis even though it is a regulated
form of cell death on so i don't think
that i would go as far as to say that
that all of your cells were eventually
going to die this way
but it's sort of a very common
maintenance way for cells to die and be
replaced
cool
thanks emily thanks david